y japón sus templos y el monte fuji
maravillas que los turistas extranjeros
podrán admirar una vez más desde este
viernes cuando el país reabre
paulatinamente sus puertas a los
viajeros tras dos años de cierre debido
a la pandemia un largo periodo que se
explica por la propia naturaleza de los
japoneses
esto se debe a la naturaleza
conservadora de los japoneses que son
muy cautelosos y esta es una de las
razones por las que apoyan todas las
medidas que puedan evitar un
resurgimiento del coronavirus
y
una reapertura que está acompañada de
medidas drásticas en principio sólo
pueden venir viajeros de 98 países entre
ellos francia donde el virus circula
poco incluso los vacunados deben
presentar una prueba pcr negativa y
contratar un seguro médico privado en el
país se tiene que usar mascarilla y ser
acompañados durante toda su estadía por
guías encargados de vigilar que se
cumplan las normas con esto las
autoridades esperan reactivar su
economía a pesar de todo una cosa
decaiga esperamos que la reanudación del
turismo ayuda a impulsar la economía
local mantendremos el esfuerzo para
reactivar la demanda turística mientras
equilibramos las medidas de control de
infecciones y las actividades sociales y
económicas esto es de marca de todo
antes de la pandemia japón dependía en
gran medida del turismo para sustentar
su economía en 2019 el país recibió a
casi 32 millones de visitantes
extranjeros que generaron 40 mil
millones de euros o el 1 por ciento de
su producto interno bruto la pandemia
arruinó el objetivo establecido de 40
millones de visitantes esperados para
los juegos olímpicos que finalmente se
celebraron a puerta cerrada